die
Sookie sucking now
hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
new flash footage it's actually behind
the scenes video but there are a bunch
of things that weren't in the past
trailer so there's going to be a
breakdown of that as well as who's going
to be in that first episode there's a
huge cast so first things first we see
two different versions of the suit
there's him with the white emblem and
with the old emblem so at some point in
the episode we're gonna see the
transition and if you guys didn't see
they kind of explained on social what
the timeline was going to be this is
picking up six months after the events
of the finale so it's been a long time
the title of the episode is the man who
saved central city and in some of these
other images they released you can see
they're having a big celebration for him
the city is unlike a flash high like
they totally loved him but the twist is
is that Barry is kind of torn up inside
because Eddie is the one that really
saved the day if he hadn't killed
himself the reverse flash would it
totally killed Barry so if you remember
at the beginning arrow season 3 like
whenever they picked up they had been
kicking ass for like three or six months
you know however long the jump was
between season 2 and season 3 of that
show it's going to be kind of the same
thing on the flash they'll have just
been kicking ass this whole time that's
why you see them high-fiving each other
so much a lot of the behind-the-scenes
stuff shows how they're doing the atom
smasher effects now I know of you guys
have probably seen ant-man so you know
he shrinks down and he grows big but the
difference between ant-man's powers and
atom smashers powers is that as atom
smasher gets bigger he actually doesn't
lose density a man size is limited to
about 30 feet like if he gets any bigger
than his bones won't be strong enough to
hold all that weight atom smashers bones
break and regrow as he gets bigger and
bigger how many of you saw this and
thought this might be Gorilla Grodd now
he's not listed in this episode but he's
totally gonna be back in season 2 so
don't worry we also see him fighting
captain cold and heat wave this has been
a little while so they probably been
trying to steal a whole bunch of stuff
since the finale yes they're going on
legends of tomorrow they're going to be
kind of like anti-heroes but at this
point in the narrative there's still
full blown rogues still trying to steal
all kinds of stuff from under the
flashes nose let's work down the cast
list here so there's a whole bunch of
people in this episode and a lot of them
we haven't seen in the trailers yet so
just going down the list both current
halves of firestorm including Ronnie
Raymond in Martin Stein two more Barnes
the actor who's playing talk amok he's
going to be a character at STAR Labs
he's going to be hired by caitlin now
don't know if he's going to get any kind
of superhero cost
but in the comics he's actually a
firestorm villain that tries to go
around creating nuclear reactions
destroying stuff so those are they're
changing the character just a little bit
and remember we have the earth to
dynamic happening so like atom smasher
for instance in the comics he's actually
a good character but this version on the
TV show is evil earth to atom smasher we
know a lot of people are coming from
Earth to but we don't know how many of
them are going to be evil versions of
characters that are typically good in
the comics that's gonna be like one of
the most fun things like seeing really
big heroes from the comics that actually
show up is earth two villains further
down the list a character named Greg
Turk that's actually who this is and
everyone was wondering who this is he's
a relatively minor Young Justice
character he has like archery skills
he's a protege of Malcolm Merlyn so it
looks like the TV show is just doing
their own version of him no idea what
his powers will be Linda Park is back
Wally West is supposed to appear not
obviously this is just based on the IMDb
page a lot of times people post false
stuff on IMDb but the flash TV shows
IMDB page doesn't get trolled the way
Game of Thrones IMDB page does so I'm
taking most of this as being accurate
but we also got hot girl Jay Garrick of
course and then supposedly we're gonna
see some form of zoom we're not supposed
to full-on meet him till episode 2
that's called the flash of two worlds I
love that they chose the second episode
to be the flash of two worlds and then
finally we have patty spivot who I think
is coming from earth-2 but that's not
confirmed it looks like she's going to
be a regular cop that gets up to
Detective because she's going to be Joe
West new partner r.i.p Eddie pour one
out for him really the big surprise for
me looking at this big cast list is that
we're gonna meet Jesse quick and Wally
West right away so I mean at least we
won't have to wonder what's going on
with them especially the mystery behind
wallet West you guys can let me know
like what is your theory about where he
comes from and how he is related to iris
and Joe like is he a cousin is he a
mystery baby that Joe had is he from
earth-2 I still kind of like the theory
that zoom is an evil future version of
wally west from earth-2 well I mean
we'll have to see it's just that if
you've read the new 52 comics and you
know about Daniel West that version the
reverse-flash just think about how Wally
West might fit into that congratulations
to the winner of my first reverse flash
ring giveaway Alex Chung be sure to
private message me on the back end of my
channel so and get your contact
info I'll be giving you a gift
certificate so that you can get the ring
off of entertainment earth so there's
three more weeks to go before air on
flash come back and we're going to get
like a little bit of new footage each
week so I'll do you know new trailer
breakdowns each week and give away a new
reverse flash ring each time I have to
do the end of that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment whenever I post a
flash or arrow video really really
simple I'm also working on some cool
merch but I'm not quite ready to tell
you guys about it I'll just say that
it's arrow and flash related so get
pumped about that and for those that are
asking about vixen yes I am doing a
vixen video this week that'll be my next
video so why does wait for all that
stuff you can click here for all my
flash trailer videos whole bunch of
flash footage and you can click here for
all my arrow footage thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight